welcome to
ramsey in 10 where i'm challenging some
of my favorite chefs to prove that all
you need to make a stunning dish
is literally 10 minutes with some
amazing ingredients now today i'm
challenging someone who i think you may
know
someone that i know can almost cook
anything on the planet
someone who really knows these beef
wellingtons all of you please welcome
the amazing me that's right today i'm
going to show you how to make the most
amazing shrimp scampi
in literally 10 minutes let's have 10
minutes on the clock you guys ready
let's go now the first thing you need of
course you get that water boiling
90 of this battle is all about the prep
okay so
shrimp scampi i'm going to start off
with a shallot i'm gonna chop that
don't go find ice just slice it okay
again a lot quicker
so slice it in half okay if you slice it
too thin it's gonna burn so just slice
do nice slices
beauty done
i like the shallots over the onion the
shallots make it a little bit sweeter
and more importantly it's a lot easier
to digest
slice the onions don't get too fancy
okay
from there a little splash
of olive oil now water's boiling
splash oil in splash the oil in i
actually like this with a little bit of
heat in there okay so
i've got some chili flakes i'm gonna
finish up some fresh basil
once the oil is up to temp slots in now
caramelize those slots lightly season
them okay
a bit of salt and pepper and don't worry
if they don't break down immediately by
the time they're cooked
they'll start breaking down now
from there a little drizzle aloe vera
okay get that turning in break down the
shallots
now when you're cooking and you're up
against it time wise
trust me start using techniques rather
than chopping everything so i've got
this microplane that we use
obviously to grate parmesan lemon
take a nice clove of garlic okay and
literally
grate that over those shallots the
garlic disintegrates so much quicker
okay you get right down to the wire and
look
underneath there it's beautiful
it sort of almost purees the garlic for
you and then from there
take a little knife and take that all in
there
so tap it
and literally get that really nice
caramelization on that garlic and those
wonderful shallots
now once you've round off the shallots
okay
from there literally turn up the heat
get that really nice and hot now start
off too hot and you'll burn those
shallots
okay checking on the thyme now
a little touch of chili flake okay chili
flakes in there
lightly sprinkle those chili flakes you
can always add more heat we can't take
it away so be smart with that
and then get your tomatoes i want a
little bit of acidity in this dish
and again i'm gonna just cut these
tomatoes in half okay
and what's that gonna do it's gonna
blister in the pan
but more importantly it's gonna give it
that really nice sweetness
three or four little cherry tomatoes
okay and that's where the acidity comes
in
open them up and you'll hear them sort
of almost
start to blister and roast now
as the tomatoes start to break down okay
my shallots are caramelizing the garlic
has disintegrated beautifully
break those down and then from there i'm
gonna deglaze the pan
basically i'm gonna sort of clean the
pan out with a little tablespoon
of white wine white wine goes in
turn up the gas
break that down now look what's
happening the tomatoes are
disintegrating
the shallots are super caramelized that
garlic's disappeared
chili flakes give it the heat and then
from there
a tablespoon of stock vegetable stock
chicken stock
or even fish stop in don't flood it okay
[Applause]
i'm trying to create a really nice sauce
you don't start cooking your pasta
until that is absolutely ready okay
now once that's on and it starts
to sort of reduce down literally
back on how long we got
oh my lord i'll go for a run get your
pan on
keep that boil rolling for your pasta
get your pan on nicely now look at that
it's reduced down to a syrup
this is where it goes even more fragrant
take your basil
get your largest leaf your small leaves
on the outside
okay and from there
the nice thing about that get your large
leaf okay get the small leaves
tuck them inside the large leaf and roll
it
like a beautiful big cigar okay hold it
nice and tight
let the knife do the work and
literally chiffonade that basil now
here's where it goes up a notch okay
that's beautifully caramelizing down
there okay
nice basil goes on
so we're halfway just under five minutes
to go capers
a little bit of the acid and saltiness
there but look
that's the sauce that's where the magic
is
right there so we're halfway now
take your shrimp okay lightly season the
shrimp
salt and pepper season nicely
salt pepper okay
get them really nicely seasoned they
only take literally 90 seconds to cook
90 cents for the pasta 90 seconds for
the shrimp
okay my pan is nice and hot
a teaspoon of olive oil in there in with
a pasta
and look i want color on those shrimp
they go in
beautiful shrimp are in
don't oversee these shrimp okay they
turn dry
so the nice thing now is the shrimper on
sauce is ready
take your capellini in
to your water okay in
that starts to boil up take it twist it
around
and it literally cooks in 90 seconds
turn up the gas turn that around and
you'll see that coming together
beautifully
time please how long left
once that shrimp are coloured long take
them off the gas
turn them around okay
look at the color on there beautiful
really beautiful
pasta is boiling
watch olive oil on top beautifully done
take that zest of lemon and i want to
literally
zest my lemon
over there look at that we're just under
three minutes to go
pasta's cooking nicely i'm using a
cappellini okay
so it's super thin and really quick to
cook
i haven't over filled the pan with water
sometimes you put too much water in the
pan you lose the capillini
so keep the water to a minimum
shrimp beautifully rested i'm going to
put them
in to my sauce there just like that
bring that back up to temp
now look the less water you've got in
that pasta
the quicker it cooks okay and from there
take that out check still nice and firm
so
literally another 30 seconds in there
sometimes when you fill up a pan with
water you put your capolini in
and you lose it all so i like the small
pan half full of water
and so the pasta cooks quicker but you
don't lose any
shrimp resting back inside the shallots
and the blister tomatoes
and look
so just under two minutes to go
cappellini literally
is if you go through it with your
fingers
it's cooked colander in back over
out draining under the pan
i like putting the caffeine back into
the pan and then literally mixing that
around glazing it with oil
60 seconds to go now
shrimp cappellini i'm going to mix that
shrimp
with my capolini beautifully done
in not too much pasta remember the
heroes the shrimp
and then look i'm mixing this all up now
beautifully done
i'm going to twist that round i'll sit
the pasta
beautifully in the center of the plate
and then garnish that with my shrimp
now i want all those shallots
and all that beautiful sauce and look
how do i finish that for dinner
honestly parmesan
over the top right at the last minute
and then finally just a nice
pinch of zest and then
very quickly the lemon
and fresh lemon and there you have the
most amazing
shrimp cappellini done in 10 minutes
do not forget to subscribe to my amazing
youtube channel and good luck
can't wait to see what you can do in 10.